so for them they might have Ferraris and
that's fine I don't have a problem of
that but they don't what other peoples
have Ferraris because for them that's
really the mass consumption for a lot of
the growth skeptics is really despicable
I am Nicholas be with recent TV today
we're talking to Daniel Benna me author
of the new book Ferraris for all in
defense of economic progress thanks for
joining us good to be here who the hell
is against economic progress well a lot
of people ask me that I think a lot of
people because the book is really aimed
at the mainstream elite who in my view
are very nervous and skeptical about
economic growth so who are the types of
elites that are against economic
progress and by progress you mean kind
of more and more stuff for more and more
people yeah I mean increasing economic
output and I see that as central to
social progress more broadly defined as
well and the people who are against it I
think are the mainstream political class
and a lot of the mainstream business
class as well so it's not a book about
hardcore deep greens at all right it's
much more about the mainstream and I
think the way they express their anxiety
about economic growth is not to say
growth is bad we hate prosperity it's to
introduce all of these caveats and
introduce the idea that there are limits
to growth their environmental limits so
yeah let's talk about the environmental
limits what is the typical
environmentalist caveat against economic
progress I think it's changed a bit over
the years because initially if you go
back to the 1970s a lot of it was about
resources that oh my god if we grow too
fast and we become too prosperous the
world will run out of resources and
we'll be in serious trouble in Britain's
that's what they were arguing I think
more recently it's more become more
precautionary so climate changes we
could example that where they'll say
well maybe we're okay at the moment but
we're stirring up huge problems for
ourselves in relation to the future
therefore climate change is not
a scientific or practical problem it's a
problem that means that we have to hold
back on growth we have to restrain
ourselves that's the argument that they
use what's what's wrong with that
argument so you know if everybody in the
world has a car and they're polluting or
their own factory or something that it's
going to destroy the environment what
what's wrong with that way of thinking I
don't see it as being a limit in the
sense they see it as being a limit I
said as posing a challenge to humanity
but it's a challenge that we can
overcome through better engineering
through adapting to climate change for
example by having high sea sea walls by
may be investing more nuclear energy may
be having more high-tech solutions geo
engineering solutions like pulling
carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere so
I'm not an engineer so I don't know the
precise solutions are the best but I'm
confident that it doesn't provide an
insurmountable limit we can grow and in
fact that's the best way to find
solutions to the problem you talked
about the business class being against
economic progress now how do you make
sense of that because don't they want to
have bigger market so that they're
selling more and more stuff to more and
more people yeah I mean growth
skepticism as I defined it is a sense of
real ambivalence about economic growth
and prosperity so they're torn so on the
one hand of course there is an
imperative for them to increase profits
to grow to expand on the other hand
they're very nervous about it and the
way that often expresses itself is in
terms of corporate ethics or corporate
governance or corporate social
responsibility which is essentially
saying we've got to be really we do need
to grow but we need to be really careful
about it we need to be cautious about
how we go ahead because we could cause
all sorts of problems what are the types
of problems that they're worried about
it could be all sorts of things it could
be that they would cause environmental
problems it could be I suppose people
might react badly to what they're doing
but they look bad and their reputation
will suffer as a result the reputational
risk can be is is any part of it that if
everyone has a Ferrari suddenly a
Ferrari is on such a status symbol yeah
that's nothing that's find interesting
arguments although I don't really agree
with
because I think it brings out the
elitist character and the argument
because I see this fundamentally as an
elite argument because what they're
really saying is that the world can't
really grow we don't really believe in
prosperity so we have to protect what
we've got ourselves so for them they
might have Ferraris and that's fine I
don't have a problem of that but they
don't want other people to have Ferraris
because for them that's really the mass
consumption for a lot of the growth
skeptics is really despicable so it's
okay for them to have a Ferrari but not
for the majority of the population
Arthur is is gross skepticism one of the
main kind of excuses of wealth I mean
you see it more in the first world than
the third one right in men in the West
we've had quite slow growth during a lot
of the post-second World put boardwalk
period especially since the 1970s
especially since 2008 with the recession
so one way to rationalize that is not to
say let's have more growth is go forward
is to say well this is natural that's
just the way things are you have slowed
growth you can't do anything about it I
think there's also the
deindustrialization of the West so as a
proportion of output industry is
becoming less and less important and a
lot of the Western elite I think feels
estranged from the world of production
and manufacturing and probably most
important there's a lack of belief in
social progress people don't think that
progress is possible or they think it
would cause all sorts of problems and as
I say I think economic growth is really
central to a classical conception of
progress I want to thank Daniel benim
Eve Arthur of Ferraris for all in
defense of economic progress for talking
to reason TV today I'm Nick Gillespie
thank you thank you